hey what's up people of the internets
today you're not even gonna believe this
we're with ellie holcomb rockstar
author supermom um just all around rad
human being we're gonna talk about
our own mental health journeys winning
won't make you well kids
families to all of it but first we've
got to start with this incredible book
that you just wrote
this was on my desk and so i road tested
this
and a couple of things happened number
one
i don't like tearing up in front of my
kids so that was number one ellie
holcomb party foul
number one thanks a lot number two about
two-thirds of the way through this when
you're with
you know this when you're connecting
with an audience yes and you are about
two-thirds way through a song
and there's this moment when your
hands disconnect and they're just doing
it yep
and your voice is still going but your
head
comes back 100 and you know we're having
a thing
yeah right and that's what all of us who
connect right yep
there was that moment with just four
wackadoodlonies sitting
on a pile of blankets going
oh we're all in a thing and then my
four-year-old
started singing this my son
comes in and starts singing it and my
wife they have this whole alt
holcomb universe so dude
number one you've created magic here you
gave my family
you gave my family a corona moment
right and it was just so
beautiful and then explaining all of
this
and my wife is her her expertise is
literacy so when i try to figure out i
don't know what she does she's just way
smarter than me but
she teaches teachers how to teach kids
how to read it's amazing she was
stopping this
and saying this is the most
sociologically correct this was really
thought out oh
does that make sense yeah you were hyper
intentional about how you wrote this
yes to make sure that every kid who
picked this up felt like
they were represented here and they
belonged here that's exactly that's a
huge deal
right huge deal so i have to know how
this came about
how did you how did this come about yeah
so okay so you know i just
i loved i love that i i love
that this book made it to the bed pile
it is on the rotation
it is bed pile approved this is amazing
i
so it is it's so it's so sweet to hear
stories like that because i wrote this
so
i did this start as a song no so this
one actually this one did my first one
didn't the song came later
but i started singing i had this melody
in my head and
so i actually wrote the book to this
melody that's
on the record which is a really fun it's
a great editing tool okay if anybody's a
writer
if you're writing children's books a
song has to be short
like you don't get that many words you
can fit a lot in but then you're like
almost into rap so
it's like so there's just only so it was
a really helpful
um thing for me to sing it and it was so
fun when i would talk with my
my um anr and editor
woman sweet michelle at lifeway at b h
she was just she would sing it back to
me so we were literally like singing on
the phone i'm like okay and then we
could sing like this
and so she it has been but what i wanted
to do i signed a two book deal with them
and when i was trying to write this
second book i'm in the phase of
three young children and it's busy yeah
and i am like okay can we say that it's
busy is a
exhausted mom's way of saying this super
sucks it's a little bit of good
really hard with a little bit of good
yes no it's
really hard yeah like it is and you're
um
i i i was laughing i was telling my kids
the other day i was like guys
i am so thankful for y'all it was a good
moment you know it's like one of those
good moments where like
snuggling reading a book it's like our
version of the pile we're on the
soft carpet in their room and so i'm
like i am so
thankful that y'all are my kids and i
get to be your mom
they were like yeah mom if you didn't
have us you would be
bored
they're like you probably just like
watch tv all day
and i was like i'm like no that i would
do that but yeah
and and my five-year-old was like yeah
that would actually be pretty super cool
that's true buddy um but it is it is
it is like the days
are busy some days they are exhausting
sometimes i feel like a
total failure at the end of the day and
um
and and they're wonderful days there are
so many wonderful moments
but they are full yeah and so i just
like there's not a lot of margin
if that makes sense so i was just like
i'm like i tell my kids so many things
throughout the day like
okay flush the toilet please for the
love like flush the toilet because the
baby loves the toilet and so when you
don't flush it the baby touches whatever
like he
anyway whatever so he loves toilets and
choking hazards so we're just talking
a lot about rules say please and thank
you be kind
we're we share in this family we're a
family that welcomes people
you know there's all these things that
i'm communicating but at the end of the
day
um like i'm like am i communicating the
truth that i want them to know the very
most at the depths of their being
and a lot of days i get to the end of
the day and i'm like hadn't done that
once
i'm like everybody's alive we didn't go
to the er
right yes yes we mainly washed our hands
for the most part before we ate but
and we said please and thank you but i
don't know that we've done this and so
but
every night we have our version of the
bed pile so every night we
sing and we read and we pray and we
snuggle and so
i just thought man what if i could write
a book that not only would help my kids
remember what's true and what really
counts at the end of the day
but like that would help me to remember
because i it
i forget what's true all the time and
and so
um it's just so sweet what you described
because my prayer for this book is that
it would be like a campfire for families
to gather around at the end of this
that's what it is
like warm your heart warm your soul by
the light of god's love
and yes so you just literally described
that moment i'm like oh my gosh
and so for what it's worth it passed the
literary critic
it passed the like john deloney is
everyone represented in this
like i love it like the failed woke
20 year old guy it passed all that and
it passed like the like
family unification moment in the big
pile right it's sweet it's such a
sweet just a beautiful gift thank you
it's incredible well it's been a really
it's been a really big gift to um i and
i love that you're
mentioning just that everyone is
represented and
um it was super intentional on on my
part i
uh my friend dorina williamson she wrote
this she's written a series of wonderful
children's books but one of them is
called colorful
yeah and so she talks about how it's not
great to be colorful
blind but colorful because god made the
world that's right right
and he wants us to celebrate it so it
has been so sweet
um having more intentional conversations
with my kids about that
in this moment that we're in for them to
read this book and be like mom
it's colorful like there's so many kids
in this book and they could be
they're from all over the world probably
and i'm like yes
and kayla here in the illustrator just
does such a great job
that's beautifully done it's so it's so
uh
welcoming it's a welcoming book and
somehow she
somehow a picture of a little girl
kissing a rhinoceros doesn't feel weird
it feels inviting right i'm like yeah of
course that's what you do
do not kiss rhinoceroses if you see them
or
or yes do you do yes do that no it's
just beautiful
so well done road tested this is legit
it's so good
thank you so much and i would consider
you in a class of
is it any of this is fair to say like
jesus rock
royalty okay you've got great
like a pedigree right and then
like um i remember i don't remember was
maybe 10 or 15 years ago
um when this little wackadoo community
the rabbit room came up and andy
peterson just
lost his mind and you know he's a stoic
the s philosopher yes but then this
like over this this bubbly praise as he
i remember the stories he said he walked
into a room
and heard your voice wafting through
right yeah and then all of a sudden
you are this gifted songwriter um
you're this gifted performer and
then you've got drew who's just it's
just it's just
got its own his own saintly gifts right
mm-hmm so
in growing up around a bunch of
songwriters who
went for it and everyone to be bebo 25
years ago and
no one was right you remember that that
squad of course
yes um our cadence they all want to be
one of those two right yes and
then i moved to nashville and i'm
working at belmont yeah and everyone
comes in
and they're so talented and they're so
gifted they've got all this stuff
um one of the things that's that's
continued to replay itself over and over
in my career as i've worked with
fancy pants professionals and when i got
into
um get another taking a mental health
journey
yup it's this this one line keeps coming
up over and over in my life
and that is winning won't make you well
and so when i was
18 when i was 22 and i was 25 now that
i'm
i'm old and then i work with these young
kids
it keeps coming back to when it won't
make you well so i want to that's a long
exposition to say
by all accounts you've won right
you like got to see some of the most
influential records made behind closed
doors yeah
you're an extraordinary songwriter um
you bring families together with your
art
right yeah you married a great artist
who's kind you've got a you're a great
mom of kids
like walk me like that's all cool and
then the lights go down and then
everybody gets back on the bus
and everybody gets off the bus and they
go home right
so as comfortable as you feel uh as
comfortable as you feel
diving into it i'd love to hear about
the last 15 20 years
of losing yeah not so much that but
at some point these these studio lights
go off yeah
the microphone button goes off and then
i'm forced to look in the mirror and see
who's this guy
right so tell me about that journey well
when i say losing i'm more mean like
being lost and yeah being found in those
last places okay
because that's what i that's kind of how
i would
uh describe it yeah i love just such
kind
words that you just said and i just love
that you
know because you've done this too like
on this journey of life that it's that
it that is not
the whole story and as much as i can
if ever i am on a stage i try to talk
about
um i when i was you know
starting to do my own music i was
terrified i didn't honestly didn't want
to do i wanted to be a stay-at-home mom
i'd actually quit my husband's band and
then since the lord's name would you be
willing to go do music and i'm like
no i'm not absolutely not like no that
is this is the worst timing no
and um it has been so beautiful because
um i it is it has just been the whole
thing that i felt like god was asking me
to do because i was on my own counseling
journey
um going back to
uh i just spent my life running from
pain and hiding
yep so i just i was a liar i didn't know
that i was yeah i just didn't want to
face anything that was hard and so i
didn't and so it just
festered and i was unwell and so
um i any time i just the thing that i
felt like god asked me to do was would
you be willing to go
sing songs because my word has been an
anchor for you in these low
lost losing places these dust places
of visiting brokenness and of being
scared or worried or afraid or of
anxiety
all of that stuff would you be willing
to go
uh be broken in front of people and
in front of my church and i'm like
absolutely not
i've been in those views i know what it
is to be judgmental i mean i have been
that like self-righteous person
growing up in in the church thinking
loving god is being good
and and being good enough and loving
other people enough and that's all good
and well but that's not the gospel
right it's not like that is not the
gospel and so
um so i think for me uh
i i have been on a journey
uh started a counseling journey uh and
and my counselor said porter's call
you're amazing they're amazing when i
went in for the first time
i literally went to counseling for the
first time and i was like
so i have this friend and she was like
oh
i'm like that's awesome i'm like i'm so
sorry but i was like they are having a
really hard time and i am
only here to just know how to help them
so in my very first counseling graduate
class they said the first rule of
counseling is your clients will lie to
you
so but that's what's crazy i didn't even
know
i was lying yeah yeah of course i was so
used to and i don't know what it is
about growing up in the church
that promotes hiding and i guess it's
just in scripture from the very
beginning like
the garden yeah like what if you like
their height like it's exposed
from the beginning and so um and it's
and grace is offensive
so it is hard to say like i
screwed up and i need grayson i want to
earn my worth but
that's not what the gospel is and so um
so
i am so grateful she was like i want you
to think about salsa
at the end so i like talk for whatever
30 minutes and she's like
okay so actually you need intense
counseling and i was like
huh me and she was like i want you to
think about salsa and i was like i
love salsa so i'm here for this and
she's like mild medium hot
and she said mal's gonna look like you
come in here once a year to talk about
your friend or whatever else is going on
and we can talk that through
medium will look like a need to know
basis like you have a hard conversation
you want to talk through that
something's difficult in your life you
can talk through that
she was like hot's gonna look like
laying out your personality across the
gospel and exposing some
pretty serious sin patterns that are in
your life that you don't even know are
there
um and she was like it will be hard
you're gonna you're gonna not want to
come back most times when you come in
um she was like so you can choose mild
or medium and in 10 to 12 years your
life will
completely fall apart or you can choose
hot that's so
great and so like she should win an
award
no with fear and dribbling i'm like
hot yeah right and there was something
in me that felt so relieved
to know that i wasn't gonna have to hide
or pretend
or posture myself um
[Music]
to be okay yeah yeah anymore so were you
married by this point i was married
three years into marriage
which is what i've heard three years in
a marriage you everyone realizes they
married the wrong person
because they were a human right right
right year two was for me yeah yeah
yeah so it's like that time where you're
like oh this is
tough and and what was amazing is
um so basically she just repeated the
invitation that jesus gives to all of us
that where there's truth there's freedom
and i had spent my whole life running
from the hard things and brene brown
says this too like
you can spend your life running from
it's really hard to stand up in the
truth of the brokenness in your story
right that's really hard right it is
a great deal harder to spend your life
running from it yeah and so
there was this invitation to just
sit in the places that were so wounded
in me
and um and things that i was ashamed of
didn't want anyone else to know
i just it was an invitation to
let freedom come to the places that were
the most broken
and it has been the places that have
been the most broken the dark places
that i didn't want anybody else to know
about
that has been those are the stories that
i point to to say
i know that god is real because i have
seen him meet me
and the pit of my own
self awfulness my worst decisions
the things that i wanted to stay in the
dark forever he
brought light into those places and love
and grace
and tenderness and kindness and healing
to places
i didn't even know he would touch right
and so
i just it it was it changed
my relationship with myself with the
lord
with my husband and then that has been a
trickle-down effect
for where it's like my whole life
is totally different and there's freedom
that i never knew
and this is andrews this is where andrew
peterson comes in because
his book i don't know if you know his
book series
the wing feather saga but that there's
that story
of poto helmer who's like a reformed
pirate not like theologically
right like a pirate who has changed his
ways and he spends his whole
life afraid that anyone will know his
past
especially his family and his children
and there's this moment in the second
book where all of this is revealed um
and all the things he's ashamed of are
like brought to light
and and he says after this happens uh
he's on a ship at the time which is
ironic because he was a pirate
and he's not anymore but he says this
he moved about his days with wonder
and peace because he found that his
whole story had been told and he was
still loved
hmm and i read that and i was like
that's exactly that's right i mean that
is it
like anyway so so that
journey of um learning
to be i'm a seven on the enneagram i
hate pain
i hate conflict i hate things that are
hard but it has been
through those hard things that i haven't
come to understand the power of the
gospel and empower god's love for us
and so i'm so grateful that fear didn't
keep me from
uh entering into those kind of wounded
places
that's awesome well thanks for joining
me thanks for having me on this
wild internet i still don't know how all
the stuff works but
here we are i appreciate you so so much
taking time to come visit with us
so thank you so much for coming where
can everybody find you oh they can find
me at ellie holcomb.com
okay everything's there everything's
linked there but i'm on spotify
instagram facebook amazon you can get
amazon just ran a sale on these and i
was like this is cheaper than i can get
this
so that's fantastic i don't know who
runs that those sales but all of that is
available
there but all the links are on my
website ellie holcomb.com and it's hol
comb your hair hol comb your hair well
done
yes and for everybody the holcomb's
music
plays in my house more than any other
artist even more than like andrew
peterson or pantera it's the holcombs
are in there
all the time and both drew and ellie
and grab this book it's incredible thank
you so much for being with us
you're the best thank you for having me